Everywhere lately, the news seems like it's the same. You go to Germany.
最近到处都在报道同样的新闻。你去德国看看。
Germany's long-term unemployed, parents, and the country's army are among those with the most to lose from budget cuts announced yesterday.
昨天宣布的预算削减计划中，受影响最大的人群包括德国的长期失业者、父母以及军队成员。
Or England-- Here's the Prime Minister explaining that massive cuts in government are essential.
或者看看英国——首相正在解释为什么大规模削减政府开支是必不可少的。
How we deal with these things will affect our economy and our society, indeed our whole way of life.
我们如何处理这些问题将影响我们的经济和社会，实际上也会影响我们整个生活方式。
In California, Republican State Senator Bob Dutton--
在加利福尼亚州，共和党州参议员鲍勃·达顿（Bob Dutton）——
I don't think myself, my colleagues-- I don't think any of my Democrat colleagues obviously-- nobody likes making any of these cuts. We don't want to do this. This is counterproductive. I agree.
我认为我自己，我的同事——显然也不认为我的民主党同事们——没人喜欢进行任何此类削减。我们不想这样做。这适得其反。我同意。
California is not alone, of course. Forty-eight of the 50 states have budget shortfalls. And, of course, there's Greece, whose collapse is threatening the stability of the entire European Union.
当然，加州并非个例。50个州中有48个出现了预算缺口。当然，还有希腊，它的崩溃正威胁着整个欧盟的稳定。
We're standing here on this building overlooking the Parliamentary square, and we could actually see into the crowd when it turned violent. They turned, in fact, on Giannis Panagopoulos who is the head of the biggest trade union here. They beat him up, claimed that he'd sold out to the government. The crowd then turned on the parliament. They tried to storm parliament.
我们站在这座俯瞰议会广场的大楼上，当人群变得暴力时，我们实际上可以看到他们。事实上，他们把矛头指向了这里最大工会的负责人扬尼斯·帕纳戈普洛斯（Giannis Panagopoulos）。他们殴打他，声称他背叛了政府。随后人群转向议会，试图冲击议会大厦。
Everywhere, governments are cutting back. But watching this process, it's hard not to wonder if our politics are simply incapable of handling this in a thoughtful way, if our politics are just too crude for the problems that we face. In so many places, you see posturing along very familiar lines, for example, people digging in their heels against all taxes. And other people digging in their heels against any cutbacks in certain kinds of services. And it drags on for months, and we stay in crisis.
世界各地，政府都在削减开支。但在观察这一过程中，我不禁怀疑，我们的政治是否根本无法以深思熟虑的方式处理这些问题，我们的政治对于我们面临的问题是否太粗糙了。在许多地方，你可以看到基于非常熟悉的路线的姿态，例如，人们在所有税收问题上固执己见，而其他人则在某些服务的削减上死不退让。这种情况拖延了数月，而我们仍处于危机之中。
And so today, we have two stories of people trying to be thoughtful, and really step above partisan bickering, and solve these problems in the least painful way. And we hear what happens to these idealists when they confront reality. And surprise, one of them is actually successful.
所以今天，我们有两个关于人们试图深思熟虑、超越党派纷争并以最少痛苦的方式解决这些问题的故事。我们将听到这些理想主义者在面对现实时会发生什么。令人惊讶的是，其中一人确实成功了。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass with a little summer cold, but feeling just fine and excited at the amazing stories we have for you today. Stay with us.
这里是WBEZ芝加哥电台的《美国生活》（This American Life），由公共广播国际公司（Public Radio International）分发。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass），虽然带着一点夏季感冒，但我感觉很好，对今天为你们带来的精彩故事感到兴奋。请继续收听。
Act One, Mister Fix It.
第一幕，修补先生。
New York State has the same problem most states have right now, not enough money to cover its expenses. But it's reaching a crisis point in New York. This week, the government nearly shut down, because though it's two months into the new fiscal year, the legislature and governor can't agree on a budget. Every week, they pass an emergency spending bill to keep state services going. The legislators are getting pretty fried. Here are State Senators Hugh Farley and Roy McDonald.
纽约州目前正面临大多数州都有的同样问题，即没有足够的资金来支付开支。但在纽约，这已经到了临界点。本周，政府几乎停摆，因为尽管新财年已经过去两个月，立法机构和州长仍无法就预算达成一致。他们每周都通过一项紧急支出法案来维持州政府的服务。立法者们快被搞疯了。以下是州参议员休·法利（Hugh Farley）和罗伊·麦克唐纳（Roy McDonald）。
It's time to pass a budget. We've got to get this act together. It's an absolute disgrace.
是时候通过预算了。我们必须齐心协力。这简直是耻辱。
We have lost the respect, justifiably so. We've lost the respect of real people in this state.
我们已经失去了尊重，理应如此。我们失去了这个州普通民众的尊重。
What New York does have going for it is that it brought in somebody to help solve the crisis. The guy they brought in is exactly the sort of person you would hope for, nonpartisan, liked by everybody, and experienced. He stepped in and solved this kind of financial crisis, not once, not twice, but three other times in New York. Though he says he's found that this time it's different, that all of us, not just in New York but everywhere, are in uncharted territory. That we don't even understand the trouble that we're in.
纽约州确实有一个有利条件，那就是它请来了某人来帮助解决危机。他们请来的人正是你所希望的那种人：无党派、受人爱戴且经验丰富。他曾不仅一次、两次，而是三次在纽约解决过这种金融危机。尽管他说他发现这次情况不同，我们所有人，不仅在纽约，在各地，都处于未知的领域。我们甚至不了解我们所处的困境。
But before I introduce you to him, let's set the stage, especially for those of you who live far from New York. You need to understand a few things about just how terribly run New York State is. A study by the Brennan Institute named New York State the most dysfunctional state government in the country, and that was three years before the state started making national headlines by sinking far lower than anybody thought possible. At the State Capitol building in Albany a few weeks ago, I asked Karen DeWitt, the New York Public Radio reporter who covers this stuff, and some of her colleagues for a quick review of what happened. Karen started with a scandal I'd actually forgotten, the state comptroller being forced to resign.
但在向你们介绍他之前，让我们先铺垫一下背景，特别是对于那些远离纽约的听众。你需要了解一些关于纽约州治理得多么糟糕的事情。布伦南研究所（Brennan Institute）的一项研究将纽约州评为全国政府运作最失调的州，而那是在该州因沉沦到比任何人想象中更低的地步而登上全国头条的三年前。几周前在奥尔巴尼的州议会大厦，我询问了报道这些内容的纽约公共广播电台记者凯伦·德威特（Karen DeWitt）以及她的一些同事，回顾一下发生的事情。凯伦从我其实已经忘记的一起丑闻开始讲起，即州审计长被迫辞职。
Because he got in trouble for using a state car to drive around his wife. And we thought that was bad. We thought that was a terrible scandal.
因为他因使用公车接送妻子而惹上麻烦。我们当时认为这很糟糕。我们认为那是一场可怕的丑闻。
It would pale against what happened next. Eliot Spitzer came in as governor, and began berating legislators, even allegedly sicced a state trooper on the senate majority leader, a somewhat of a Troopergate scandal. All prologue to March 10, 2008, which was, coincidentally, Erin Billups' first day as a political reporter for New York One TV.
与接下来发生的事情相比，这简直相形见绌。埃利奥特·斯皮策（Eliot Spitzer）担任州长，开始训斥立法者，甚至据称指使州警对付参议院多数党领袖，这就是所谓的“州警门”（Troopergate）丑闻。这一切都是2008年3月10日的前奏，那天巧合地是艾琳·比拉普斯（Erin Billups）作为纽约一台（New York One TV）政治记者的第一天。
And I was driving to the Capitol, and I was excited about my first day of work. And I got a call from my producer that was like, "Ah, have you heard the news?" And I was like, "No." And they're like, "Oh well, Spitzer is involved with a prostitution ring." And I was like, "Oh, he busted a prostitution ring?" No.
我正开车去国会大厦，对工作的第一天感到兴奋。我接到制片人的电话说：“啊，你听到新闻了吗？”我说：“没有。”他们说：“哦，好吧，斯皮策卷入了一个卖淫集团。”我说：“哦，他破获了一个卖淫集团？”不。
The governor of the state of New York has reportedly told his senior officials that he was involved in a prostitution ring.
据报道，纽约州州长已告知其高级官员，他卷入了一个卖淫集团。
Sources are telling Fox News Channel that Governor Spitzer is expected to resign.
消息人士告诉福克斯新闻频道，预计斯皮策州长将会辞职。
So what happened after that, David Paterson became governor. The day after he became governor, he had a press conference to tell us about adulterous affairs he and his wife had had, just to get it out of the way.
那么那之后发生了什么，大卫·帕特森（David Paterson）成了州长。在他就任州长的第二天，他召开新闻发布会告诉我们他和他妻子曾经的婚外情，只是为了把这事说清楚。
I betrayed a commitment to my wife several years ago, but both of us committed acts of infidelity.
我几年前背叛了对妻子的承诺，但我们俩都犯了不忠的行为。
You know, he starts talking, and immediately we realized what he's starting to tell us. And we're all looking at each other like, oh my gosh, not again.
你知道，他开始说话，我们立刻意识到他要告诉我们什么。我们都面面相觑，心想：天哪，又来了。
Kyle Hughes is a 20-year vet covering the Capitol, now for NYSNYS.com.
凯尔·休斯（Kyle Hughes）是一位报道州议会20年的老手，现在为NYSNYS.com工作。
He'd given us way too much information, just stuff that you don't necessarily want to hear from your governor. It's like hearing from your dad.
他给我们提供了太多信息，简直是你不想从州长那里听到的事情。就像听你父亲说的一样。
A prime example, Paterson told The Daily News that he would sometimes take his wife to the same hotel that he had gone to have affairs, the Days Inn in Harlem, on the advice of a counselor who told them to spice things up in their marriage.
一个典型的例子是，帕特森告诉《每日新闻》，他有时会带妻子去他曾经有外遇的同一家酒店，即哈莱姆区的戴斯酒店（Days Inn），这是心理医生的建议，让他们为婚姻增添情趣。
And, what was the next thing that happened? I guess there was a coup in the State Senate.
然后，接下来的事情是什么？我想州参议院发生了一场政变。
Right, a coup. Here's how that went down. The Democrats had just won the State Senate for the first time in four decades, but they only had a two vote majority. There were 32 Democrats, 30 Republicans. Until, in June 2009, two Democrats made a deal where they switched sides. They became Republicans in exchange for top Republican positions with a lot of power, which suddenly gave the Republicans control of the Senate. Now, they were the ones with a 32-30 majority. And their first order of business? Voting out the Democratic head of the Senate, and replacing him with one of their own.
没错，一场政变。事情是这样的。民主党四十年内首次赢得了州参议院，但他们只有两票的多数席位。有32名民主党人，30名共和党人。直到2009年6月，两名民主党人达成协议并倒戈。他们为了获得大量权力的共和党高层职位而变成了共和党人，这突然使共和党人控制了参议院。现在，他们以32对30拥有多数席位。他们的第一项议程？投票罢免民主党参议院领袖，并用他们自己的人取代他。
I have to say it was almost kind of breathtaking, because they stood  up, and we couldn't even figure out what they were doing at first. They said, "OK, we're making this motion. We're all going to vote."
我不得不说这简直令人震惊，因为他们站了起来，起初我们甚至弄不清他们在做什么。他们说：“好的，我们提出这个动议。我们都要投票。”
All in favor on Senator Winner going to the Chair, stand and raise your hands, as a temporary president.
所有赞成温纳（Winner）参议员担任议长的人，请起立并举手，作为临时议长。
I felt like we were in a third world country.
我觉得我们好像在一个第三世界国家。
Mr. President, I have the-- Mr. President, I have the floor. You have been removed from the Chair.
议长先生，我有——议长先生，我有发言权。你已经被撤出议长席了。
The Democrats turned the lights off. They tried to run out of the chamber.
民主党人关掉了灯。他们试图跑出会议厅。
Would you be quiet?
你能安静点吗？
I have the floor, Mr. President.
我有发言权，议长先生。
Mr. President, I move we adjourn.
议长先生，我动议休会。
The resolution is pending. [INTERPOSING VOICES] Immediate vote on adjournment. The resolution is pending.
决议正在审议中。[交叉说话] 立即投票休会。决议正在审议中。
They actually turned off the sound system so it couldn'te be broadcast out to anybody.
他们实际上切断了音响系统，这样任何人都无法进行广播。
Rollcall on the vote.
点名表决。
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[交叉说话]
Then, they locked the chamber, and there was an argument for a couple of days of whether this newly formed coalition would even be able to get a key to get into the Senate chamber. And finally, somebody slipped them a copy of the key, and they were able to get in.
然后，他们锁上了会议厅，关于这个新组成的联盟是否甚至能够拿到进入参议院会议厅的钥匙，他们争论了几天。最后，有人悄悄给了他们一把钥匙，他们才得以进入。
A week later, one of the defecting senators, Hiram Monserrate, decided to switch back to the Democratic Party. The Senate later kicked Monserrate out of office, by the way, after he was convicted of assaulting his girlfriend. But at the time, Monserrate's switch back to the Democrats left the Senate split down the middle, 31 Republicans, 31 Democrats. And since you need 32 votes to pass legislation, New York's legislature essentially shut down. If there'd been lieutenant governor, that would have solved the problem, because in New York, the lieutenant governor can cast a vote to break a tie in the Senate. But there was no lieutenant governor. The former lieutenant governor, David Paterson, had become the governor.
一周后，其中一名叛变的参议员海拉姆·蒙塞拉特（Hiram Monserrate）决定转回民主党。顺便提一下，参议院后来在蒙塞拉特因殴打女友被定罪后将他逐出办公室。但当时，蒙塞拉特转回民主党使得参议院分裂为两半，31名共和党人，31名民主党人。由于通过立法需要32票，纽约的立法机构基本上陷入了停顿。如果有一位副州长，那将解决这个问题，因为在纽约，副州长可以投票打破参议院的僵局。但当时没有副州长。前副州长、大卫·帕特森已经成为了州长。
And so Paterson decided to appoint somebody to the job. But they needed somebody that people respected, somebody whose allegiances and history would not be an issue. And that's when he reached out to a 75-year-old veteran of New York crises, the hero of our story today, Richard Ravitch. And Paterson offered Ravitch the job.
因此，帕特森决定任命某人担任该职务。但他们需要一个人们尊重的人，一个其效忠对象和历史不会成为问题的人。这时，他联系了一位75岁的纽约危机老将，也就是我们今天故事的主人公，理查德·拉维奇（Richard Ravitch）。帕特森向拉维奇提供了这个职位。
Well, I was totally taken aback from it. It was out of the clear, blue sky.
好吧，我完全被它惊呆了。这简直是晴天霹雳。
Ravitch is a big-bellied, ready, man, the kind of old school New Yorker who is still enjoying bacon with his breakfast and cocktails at dinner. His charm comes from his utterly straightforward frankness. Three different times when I asked people who know him to describe him, there's a moment before they speak where they pause and smile fondly at the very thought of him.
拉维奇是一个大腹便便、乐于助人的老派纽约人，仍然享受着早餐里的培根和晚餐时的鸡尾酒。他的魅力来自于他极其坦率的直言不讳。有三次当我请认识他的人描述他时，他们在说话前都会停顿一下，并因为想到他而露出亲切的微笑。
The night the governor announced his intention to appoint Ravitch to the lieutenant governors' job, Ravitch was out to dinner at a famous old New York steak house, Peter Luger's, with his wife and another couple. They got a call from the governor's lawyer saying the Republicans wanted to block the governor from appointing anybody.
州长宣布打算任命拉维奇为副州长的那个晚上，拉维奇正和他的妻子及另一对夫妇在纽约著名的老牌牛排馆彼得·卢格（Peter Luger's）吃晚餐。他们接到州长律师的电话，说共和党人想阻止州长任命任何人。
And therefore, we would like you to sign the oath of office now, and we'll send a lawyer and a notary out to wherever you are. So they came out to Peter Luger's. I signed the oath of office, raised my right hand.
因此，我们希望你现在签署就职誓言，我们将派一名律师和公证人到你所在的任何地方。所以他们来到了彼得·卢格牛排馆。我签署了就职誓言，举起了右手。
Had your meal been served yet?
你的饭上菜了吗？
No. But certainly I'd had a couple of vodkas by then.
没有。但到那时我肯定已经喝了几杯伏特加了。
And was there a part of you-- I was trying to figure out a politically sensitive way to ask this question. It was chaos out there. Did you feel like, I'm going into a madhouse?
有没有一部分你——我正在努力寻找一种政治上敏感的方式来问这个问题。外面是一片混乱。你是否觉得，我正走进一个疯人院？
Yes, but I'm also-- this sounds terribly pompous, forgive me. But I have a kind of a romance with the whole idea of government and public service. So at the same time that I knew I was going into a mad house, I also-- it was a matter of pride that perhaps I could be helpful. And there was nothing more useful I could do with my life.
是的，但我也是——这听起来非常浮夸，请原谅我。但我对政府和公共服务的整个理念有一种浪漫情怀。所以，当我明知自己要进入一个疯人院的同时，我也——这是一种自豪感，也许我能有所帮助。而且我的生活中没有比这更有用的事情了。
Ravitch was first drafted into saving New York government, back in the 1970s, by a phone call from a different governor, Hugh Carey, a man he'd never met and didn't know, to solve a crisis involving low income housing. Ravitch, at the time, was just a civic-minded guy in the construction business. He'd help to integrate the construction unions in New York. And he made it his personal mission to build low income housing. He knew all about public financing.
拉维奇最初是在20世纪70年代被另一位州长休·凯里（Hugh Carey）的一通电话征召去拯救纽约政府的，那是一个他从未见过也不认识的人，目的是解决一场涉及低收入住房的危机。当时，拉维奇只是建筑行业里一个有公民意识的人。他曾帮助整合纽约的建筑工会。他把建造低收入住房作为自己的个人使命。他非常了解公共融资。
And in 1979, he was called in to fix the New York agency that runs the subways and commuter rail lines, which were falling apart for lack of money before Ravitch turned them around. But Ravitch's greatest achievement, he was part of the small team that saved New York City from bankruptcy in 1975. He was involved in completely overhauling the way the city did its finances, and getting banks, and labor unions, and the state legislature, and the city government to do all kinds of things that they'd never done, and were reluctant to do. Ravitch was the team member who invented the method that they used to raise the short term cash the city needed.
1979年，他被召去修复纽约的地铁和通勤铁路机构，在拉维奇扭转局势之前，它们因缺乏资金而处于分崩离析的状态。但拉维奇最大的成就是，他是一个在1975年将纽约市从破产边缘拯救出来的小组的一员。他参与了彻底改革城市财政运作方式，并让银行、工会、州立法机构和市政府做各种他们从未做过且不情愿做的事情。拉维奇是那个发明了他们用来筹集城市所需短期现金方法的团队成员。
And Ravitch was the one called into action October 16, 1975, the day New York came closest to actual financial collapse.
拉维奇就是那个在1975年10月16日，即纽约最接近实际金融崩溃的那一天，被召集采取行动的人。
This is a very long story. I have notes on all this stuff. It's for a book I'll never write.
这是一个非常漫长的故事。我所有这些东西都有笔记。这是一本我永远不会写的书。
On October 16, 1975, the teachers union declared that it would not purchase $150 million in special government bonds that were being sold to raise money for the city. With the city so close to insolvency, it just seemed too risky. Ravitch knew that without this 150 million, it would be the end of the line, and throw the city into bankruptcy the next day. He couldn't stop thinking about it, and went to bed early, depressed.
1975年10月16日，教师工会宣布将不会购买为筹集城市资金而发行的1.5亿美元特别政府债券。由于城市濒临破产，这看起来风险太大。拉维奇知道，没有这1.5亿，这将是终点，并会使城市在第二天陷入破产。他无法停止思考这件事，早早就因为抑郁而上床睡觉了。
At about 10:00 at night, the phone rings. It's Governor Carey. He says, "Please come to my office." I got dressed. I went down to his office. And he was in white tie and tails. And he said, "You gotta call Shanker and get him to change his mind."
大约晚上10点，电话响了。是凯里州长。他说：“请到我的办公室来。”我穿好衣服。我去了他的办公室。他身穿燕尾服。他说：“你必须打电话给尚克（Shanker），让他改变主意。”
Shanker was Albert Shanker, head of the teachers union, an old friend of Ravitch's.
尚克是阿尔伯特·尚克（Albert Shanker），教师工会主席，是拉维奇的老朋友。
So I met Al in his apartment at 11:30 at night. I said to Al, I understood his reluctance, that I respected his dilemma. On the other hand, this is one of those unique circumstances in life where the consequences of going into bankruptcy were so disastrous, that you had to take some risks. So he didn't make up his mind. He said, "I'll call you at home, first thing in the morning."
所以我于凌晨1点30分在他公寓里见了阿尔。我对阿尔说，我理解他的迟疑，我尊重他的困境。另一方面，这是生活中那些独特的环境之一，破产的后果是如此灾难性，以至于你必须冒一些险。所以他没有下定决心。他说：“明天一早我就打电话给你。”
I got home about 6:00 AM. So I'm at home, and I'm listening to the radio and showering, because I've been up all night. And, all of a sudden, they interrupt. They said, "We're interrupting this program to announce that the City of New York is going into bankruptcy today." I never heard from Shanker.
我大约凌晨6点到家。所以我在家听收音机和洗澡，因为我通宵没睡。突然，他们中断了节目。他们说：“我们中断节目，宣布纽约市今天将进入破产程序。”我再也没有收到尚克的消息。
Finally, hours later, Shanker calls. He wants a private meeting away from the press. So Ravitch, and the governor, and some others meet Shanker at Ravitch's apartment. The beds aren't made. There's barely anything to eat. Ravitch puts out some matzah. And finally, they convince Shanker that really his back is against the wall, all of theirs is. And yes, the bonds are risky. But if New York defaults, all the city contracts would become invalid including the teachers union contract, which of course, would be awful for Shanker and his union. Shanker, reluctantly, buys the bonds and New York City is saved.
最后，几小时后，尚克打来电话。他想要一个远离媒体的私人会议。于是拉维奇、州长和其他一些人就在拉维奇的公寓里见了尚克。床没铺，几乎没什么吃的。拉维奇拿出了一些无酵饼。最后，他们说服尚克，他确实被逼到了墙角，他们所有人都是。是的，债券是有风险的。但如果纽约违约，所有城市合同都将失效，包括教师工会的合同，这对尚克和他的工会来说当然是可怕的。尚克勉强购买了债券，纽约市获救了。
And where Ravitch talks about the difference between what happened in 1975 and the financial crisis that New York State finds itself in today, and that most states find themselves in, he says that one of the big differences is something that might not seem so important or obvious to you or me. Cities can go bankrupt. But states can't. It's just the way bankruptcy works.
当拉维奇谈到1975年发生的事情与纽约州今天所处以及大多数州所处的金融危机之间的区别时，他说最大的区别之一是对于你我来说可能看起来并不那么重要或明显的事情。城市可以破产，但州不能。这就是破产法运作的方式。
And the virtue of being able to go into bankruptcy-- Everybody was terrified. It would have abrogated all existing collective bargaining agreements with all public employee unions. And it would've exposed the financial institutions. And the consequence of not doing something was so catastrophic to all the parties, and they wanted to avoid that. And they did just enough to avoid that. And now, there is no triggering event to make people recognize that this is very serious.
能够进入破产程序的优点是——每个人都吓坏了。它会废除所有公共雇员工会现有的集体谈判协议。它会使金融机构暴露。如果不采取行动，后果对各方来说都是如此灾难性的，他们想避免这种情况。他们做了足够多的事情来避免这一点。而现在，没有触发事件让人们认识到这是非常严重的。
But you think it's just as serious a crisis.
但你认为这是一个同样严重的危机。
I think it's more serious, because there is no triggering event to force the political system to address it in a serious manner.
我认为它更严重，因为没有触发事件迫使政治体制以严肃的态度去解决它。
Ravitch has turned himself into an expert on the current state budget at the request of the governor who asked Ravitch to use his expertise to shape a long term solution for New York's fiscal crisis. One of Ravitch's closest advisors in this project is the governor's budget director, Bob Megna. When I visit Megna, more than month into the fiscal year with no budget yet passed, I see a grocery bag full of bright, green, rubber balls, stress balls, sent by the National Association of State Budget Officers.
应州长的要求，拉维奇已将自己变成了当前州预算方面的专家，州长要求拉维奇利用他的专业知识为纽约的财政危机制定一个长期解决方案。拉维奇在这个项目中最近的顾问之一是州长的预算主任鲍勃·梅格纳（Bob Megna）。当我拜访梅格纳时，距离财年已经过去一个多月，还没有通过预算，我看到一个装满明亮绿色橡胶球的购物袋，这是全国州预算官员协会寄来的压力球。
[SOUND OF BALL BOUNCING]
[球弹跳的声音]
Yeah, I'll do that a lot.
是的，我经常这样做。
Just in the last month?
就在过去的一个月里？
Oh no. I've always done that, but in the last month, it's really increased in more frustrating moments.
哦，不。我一直都这样做，但在过去的一个月里，在更令人沮丧的时刻，次数确实增加了。
Not one, but two, state employees went out of the way to make sure that I understood that the state did not spend money on these balls. They were free. Megna pulls out this chart with two lines going across it. One line shows all the income that the state brings in. As you can imagine, that one's not looking so great. All states, with this recession, bring in less in taxes than they used to. That's a big part of the crisis. That line rises anemically at the rate of 3.5% increase per year. Now there's a much steeper line, twice as steep as the revenue line, showing the growth of spending by the state.
不仅一个，而是两个州雇员特意让我明白，州政府没有花钱买这些球。它们是免费的。梅格纳拿出这张横跨两条线的图表。一条线显示州政府带来的所有收入。你可以想象，那条线看起来不太好。由于这次衰退，所有州的税收收入都比过去少。这是危机的一大组成部分。那条线以每年3.5%的贫血速度增长。现在有一条更陡峭的线，是收入线的两倍陡，显示了州支出增长的情况。
Exactly. And that extends out over time. We refer to it, in fact, as the Jaws Chart in our kind of day-to-day kind of work, because it just looks like a shark's mouth wide open where the spending line is on the top, and the revenue line is on the bottom.
没错。而且它会随着时间的推移而延伸。我们实际上在日常工作中称它为“大白鲨图表”（Jaws Chart），因为它看起来就像一张大张着的鲨鱼嘴，支出线在顶部，收入线在底部。
Megna remembers the moment that Ravitch fully grasped the implications of this particular chart.
梅格纳记得拉维奇完全领会这张特定图表含义的那一刻。
I think that was an ah-ha moment for him. I think he saw the essential ingredient there, which is that this is not a one year problem. This is a four or five year problem, and that we weren't making a dent in that bigger problem. I think also the moment for him was-- and this is something every state is confronting, and it's not just New York. And I think that was another thing he noticed in talking to folks in Washington was it wasn't just New York.
我认为那是他的“啊哈”时刻。我想他看到了其中的本质因素，那就是这不是一年的问题。这是一个四到五年内的问题，而且我们没有在这个更大的问题上取得进展。我认为对他来说那一刻也是——这是每个州都在面对的问题，不仅仅是纽约。我想他在与华盛顿的人交谈时注意到的另一件事是，这不仅仅是纽约的问题。
States are in an unbelievable fiscal meltdown that has been, in my opinion, sadly underreported. States, collectively, reportedly have deficits of over $300 billion in this next fiscal year. Illinois, California, New York are most severe as I understand it. I just read in the paper this morning that Hawaii has limited school weeks to four days. And I gather there's something like a dozen states that have authorized local school boards to reduce school weeks.
各州正处于一场令人难以置信的财政崩溃中，在我看来，这场崩溃的报道严重不足。据报道，各州在下一个财年的集体赤字超过3000亿美元。据我了解，伊利诺伊州、加利福尼亚州和纽约州最为严重。我今天早上刚在报纸上读到，夏威夷已经将学周限制为四天。据我了解，大约有十几个州已经授权当地校董会缩短学周。
And when you first looked at the budget, did you suspect that this was the state that it was in? Were you surprised when you first got into the numbers?
当你第一次查看预算时，你怀疑它处于这种状态吗？当你第一次看到这些数字时，你感到惊讶吗？
Yes. I didn't know how serious the problem was. I didn't realize that the state had been faking balanced budgets for so many years.
是的。我不知道问题有多严重。我没有意识到该州多年来一直在伪造平衡预算。
This is one of the most alarming things that Ravitch found, and it bears some explaining. During the previous decade of prosperity, the state had committed itself to spending certain amounts of money on education, and state police, and healthcare, and all the other things that a state pays for. But it made those commitments without actually having enough revenue to pay for all of it. And so every year, there was a shortfall, a gap, and every year, the state had to figure out ways to plug that hole. And rather than come up with steady revenue sources, the state would invent all kinds of shenanigans to do it, what they call, one-shots. Like when Blue Cross Blue Shield went private, a billion dollars went to the state, or they borrowed against the winnings from a tobacco lawsuit, or they sold state property. The most famous example of that is when New York sold Attica prison to a private company for some quick cash, and then had to pay that company rent each year to keep using the prison.
这是拉维奇发现的最令人震惊的事情之一，这值得解释一下。在过去的繁荣十年中，该州承诺在教育、州警察、医疗保健以及州政府支付的所有其他方面花费一定的金额。但它做出这些承诺时，实际上并没有足够的收入来支付这一切。因此，每年都有一个缺口，一个差距，每年州政府都必须想出办法来填补这个漏洞。而不是提出稳定的收入来源，州政府会想出各种花招来做到这一点，也就是所谓的“一次性手段”（one-shots）。比如当蓝十字蓝盾保险公司私有化时，十亿美元流向了州政府，或者他们抵押了烟草诉讼的赔偿款，或者他们出售了州有资产。最著名的例子是纽约将阿提卡监狱（Attica prison）卖给了一家私营公司以换取快钱，然后每年必须向该公司支付租金以继续使用该监狱。
Lots of states resort to these one time gimmicks. Idaho is delaying $135 million in Medicaid payments it owes nursing homes and hospitals. New Jersey, Colorado, and Kansas put off payments that they owed state pension funds. Even during good times, they did that. That's a common one. Sometimes states will push a payday for state employees into the next fiscal year.
许多州诉诸于这些一次性的噱头。爱达荷州正在推迟支付其欠疗养院和医院的1.35亿美元医疗补助金。新泽西州、科罗拉多州和堪萨斯州推迟了它们欠州养老基金的付款。即使在经济好的时候，他们也这样做。这是一个常见的例子。有时各州会把支付州雇员工资的时间推迟到下一个财年。
Yes, in Arizona, they sold the Capitol and leased it back to plug a hole in an operating deficit.
是的，在亚利桑那州，他们出售了议会大厦并将其租回，以填补运营赤字的漏洞。
So forever into the future, they'll have to pay rent on their own Capitol building?
所以他们将来永远都要为自己的议会大厦支付租金？
That's correct.
那是正确的。
To solve a short term problem?
为了解决一个短期问题？
Yes. So eventually, you only have one Capitol building. Eventually, that's why this is not sustainable. You run out of assets to sell. But we did that in New York State during a period of unbelievable prosperity, because the political system was not willing either to cut expenditures or to impose enough taxes to pay for recurring expenses.
是的。所以最终，你只会拥有一座议会大厦。最终，这就是为什么这是不可持续的。你会耗尽可出售的资产。但我们在繁荣得令人难以置信的时期在纽约州这样做了，因为政治体制要么不愿意削减支出，要么不愿意征收足够的税款来支付经常性开支。
This past year, the one-shot that saved New York State and many other states was something that you may not have realized was being used this way, the stimulus money passed by the Obama administration. It allocated billions to go into the hands of state governments specifically to plug the gaping holes in their budgets. In New York, it was 5 billion last year, 4 billion this year.
去年，拯救了纽约州和许多其他州的一次性手段是你们可能没有意识到被这样使用的事情：奥巴马政府通过的刺激资金。它拨出数十亿资金直接交到州政府手中，专门用于填补其预算中的巨大漏洞。在纽约，去年是50亿，今年是40亿。
That money is scheduled to go away over the next two years.
这笔钱计划在未来两年内逐步取消。
Again, the governor's budget director, Bob Megna.
再次说明，州长的预算主任鲍勃·梅格纳。
That exacerbates our situation in unprecedented ways. That really has gotten us through the last year. When that money goes away, we either cut that spending, or we have to figure out a way to replace that revenue.
这以前所未有的方式加剧了我们的处境。那笔钱确实让我们度过了过去的一年。当那笔钱消失时，我们要么削减支出，要么必须想办法弥补那部分收入。
Which means that New York needs a plan. Without it, the Jaws Chart shows that New York's deficit will grow from 9 billion this year, to 13 billion next year, to 60 billion in the next five years with no end in sight. And, the longer New York waits to fix the problem, the deeper the cuts in government services will have to be.
这意味着纽约需要一个计划。没有它，“大白鲨图表”显示纽约的赤字将从今年的90亿，增加到明年的130亿，再到未来五年的600亿，而且看不到尽头。而且，纽约解决问题的时间越晚，削减政府服务就必须越深。
Any reason not to start, whoever's in charge of this? First of all, I apologize for sitting down, but it's, as I'm sure you'll appreciate, a hectic few weeks.
无论谁负责，有什么理由不开始呢？首先，我为坐下道歉，但正如我相信你会理解的那样，这几个星期真是忙乱。
In March, at a press conference in Albany, Ravitch presented his plan to resolve, long term, the state's fiscal crisis. Ravitch's proposal copies a few things from the successful scheme that fixed New York City's finances back in the '70s, like it would force the state to use what are called, Generally Accepted Accounting Principles. Yes, it sounds crazy, but many cities and states, including Florida, Texas, Ohio, and New York, don't use those accounting rules that require you to have real revenue sources to cover your debts. Switching to Generally Accepted Accounting Principles would make it much harder to do the one-shots and the one time gimmicks that have been used in the past to fix the budget in New York.
3月，在奥尔巴尼的一次新闻发布会上，拉维奇提出了他解决该州长期财政危机的计划。拉维奇的提案借鉴了70年代修复纽约市财政的成功方案中的一些内容，例如它将强制该州使用所谓的“公认会计原则”（GAAP）。是的，这听起来很疯狂，但许多城市和州，包括佛罗里达州、德克萨斯州、俄亥俄州和纽约州，都没有使用那些要求你有真实收入来源来覆盖债务的会计规则。改用公认会计原则将使过去用于修复纽约预算的一次性手段和一次性噱头变得更加困难。
Ravitch's plan also has strict procedures for when the budget slides out of balance with a control board and special powers for the governor. But the item that got the most attention in Ravitch's proposal was borrowing. Ravitch believed that, looking realistically the budget, it would be too politically painful for the legislature to make all the necessary cuts to balance the budget in just one year. And so, as a practical matter, he said, if the legislature felt a need to ramp down in four or five years to a balanced budget, his plan let them borrow money to help do it, 2 billion a year.
拉维奇的计划还为预算失去平衡时制定了严格的程序，设立了控制委员会，并赋予州长特殊权力。但拉维奇提案中引起最多关注的项目是借款。拉维奇认为，从现实的角度看预算，立法机构在短短一年内做出所有必要的削减来平衡预算，在政治上将太痛苦了。因此，作为实际问题，他说，如果立法机构觉得有必要在四五年内逐步削减至平衡预算，他的计划允许他们借钱来帮助实现这一目标，每年20亿。
I want to emphasize again, borrowing is never a good way of solving operating budget deficits. But I also know that borrowing on a short term basis was an essential tool to get us out of the mess we were in in 1975.
我想再次强调，借款永远不是解决运营预算赤字的好方法。但我同样知道，短期借款是让我们摆脱1975年困境的重要工具。
Ravitch made it clear that this borrowing was only acceptable if it was part of his bigger plan to control the budget in the future, and if it came with harsh penalties attached if the overall budget went out of balance. In the chaos of New York State politics, there was this sense, when Ravitch laid out this plan, that finally an adult had arrived in the room to restore some sanity-- at last, a nonpartisan approach, the only real solution on the table, tough medicine.
拉维奇明确表示，这种借款只有在它是他未来控制预算的更大计划的一部分，并且如果整体预算失去平衡时附带严厉惩罚的情况下才是可以接受的。在纽约州政治的混乱中，当拉维奇提出这个计划时，有一种感觉，终于有一个成年人来到房间里恢复了一些理智——终于，一个非党派的方法，桌面上唯一真正的解决方案，良药。
And after the pandemonium of the previous two years, for the Democrats who run both houses of the legislature and the governor's office by raising a serious long term solution could finally show voters that they weren't a bunch of Bozos. What happened next was nothing.
而在过去两年的混乱之后，对于那些通过提出一个严肃的长期解决方案来运行两个立法机构和州长办公室的民主党人来说，终于可以向选民证明他们不是一堆笨蛋。接下来发生的事情什么也没有。
I like many of the things that he proposes. I hold my breath on the borrowing.
我喜欢他提出的许多事情。我在借款问题上屏住呼吸。
This is State Senator Tom Libous, a Republican. Like other lawmakers that I interviewed in Albany, he fixated on the borrowing in Ravitch's plan, and said it made it unacceptable. Here's Republican Assemblyman Jim Hayes, and Republican Minority Leader Brian Kolb.
这是州参议员汤姆·利布斯（Tom Libous），共和党人。就像我采访的其他立法者一样，他盯着拉维奇计划中的借款，并说这使得它不可接受。这是共和党议员吉姆·海耶斯（Jim Hayes）和共和党少数党领袖布莱恩·科尔布（Brian Kolb）。
Almost all of the proposals that he has made are all good, but I think, unfortunately, he rolled out the proposals at the same time he rolled out a proposal to borrow $2 billion.
他提出的几乎所有建议都是好的，但我认为，不幸的是，他在提出借款20亿美元建议的同时，也提出了这些建议。
Well, I've had several meetings with the lieutenant governor. I like him. I really liked him up to the point he talked about borrowing.
好吧，我与副州长开了几次会。我喜欢他。在他谈到借款之前，我真的很喜欢他。
Keep in mind that this is the same legislature that has balanced its budgets for years using borrowing under Democrats and Republicans. And I actually heard the same from the Democrats. Here are two of the most reform minded legislators in Albany, Assemblywoman Sandy Galef and State Senator Liz Kreuger.
请记住，这就是同一个多年来在民主党和共和党人执政下通过借款来平衡预算的立法机构。实际上，我从民主党人那里也听到了同样的话。以下是奥尔巴尼最具有改革思想的两名立法者，众议员桑迪·加莱夫（Sandy Galef）和州参议员利兹·克鲁格（Liz Kreuger）。
Well, I like the way he would do the accounting. I'm not in favor of the borrowing.
好吧，我喜欢他进行会计处理的方式。我不赞成借款。
The borrowing question. The Senate, officially, has been on record as not accepting the borrowing.
借款问题。参议院正式记录为不接受借款。
Borrowing became the shorthand the politicians could use to dismiss the Ravitch plan, even though he wasn't advocating borrowing. He was just saying, if you have to, here's the one way it would be acceptable. Editorial writers condemned the borrowing. Newspapers basically reduced the plan to its borrowing. And this year, when the press corps in the State Capitol did their annual musical review, a tradition that goes back over a hundred years with reporters playing the various state politicians on stage, the reporter playing Dick Ravitch, a Capitol vet named J. Gallagher, sang this number, which tells you a lot about the reputation that Ravitch was getting.
借款成为了政客们用来驳回拉维奇计划的简写，尽管他并没有主张借款。他只是说，如果你必须这样做，这是可以接受的一种方式。社论撰稿人谴责借款。报纸基本上把该计划简化为了借款。今年，当州议会大厦的记者团进行年度音乐评论时，这是一个可以追溯到一百多年前的传统，记者们在舞台上扮演各种州政客，扮演迪克·拉维奇的国会大厦老手J·加拉格尔（J. Gallagher）演唱了这首曲子，这告诉了你很多关于拉维奇声誉的情况。
[SINGING TO THE TUNE OF "TRY TO REMEMBER"] Back in the '70s, I cooked up remedies so New York did not kick the bucket. My plan was clever, a brilliant endeavor, and it is the plan that you now should follow. You haven't tried it, but I have decided to borrow.
[演唱《尝试回忆》(Try to Remember)的旋律] 回到70年代，我炮制了补救措施，所以纽约没有死掉。我的计划很聪明，一项辉煌的努力，它是你现在应该遵循的计划。你还没有尝试过，但我已经决定要借款。
Then, it gets even more rich. While the State Senate opposed any borrowing, the other house of the legislature, the State Assembly, decided to adopt the $2 billion borrowing that Ravitch said would be acceptable, but without the stringent controls that he said had to be tied to the borrowing. The governor, meanwhile, who put Ravitch up to the task of fiscal reform, had his own priorities. His priority was trying to pass a budget which had no borrowing in it at all. And he just had a few weeks to do that.
然后，情况变得更丰富了。虽然州参议院反对任何借款，但立法机构的另一个院，州众议院，决定采用拉维奇所说的可以接受的20亿美元借款，但没有他所说的必须与借款挂钩的严格控制。与此同时，让拉维奇承担财政改革任务的州长，有他自己的优先事项。他的优先事项是试图通过一个根本没有借款的预算。而他只有几周的时间来做这件事。
And once the Assembly was using the Ravitch plan as the excuse to borrow, it became politically complicated to oppose the borrowing, but support the Ravitch plan. So while the governor didn't overtly turn his back on the plan, he didn't throw himself behind it either. He didn't make any effort to sell it to legislators, or get it turned into law, which pretty much left the plan in icy limbo.
一旦众议院利用拉维奇计划作为借款的借口，反对借款但支持拉维奇计划在政治上就变得复杂了。因此，虽然州长并没有公开背弃该计划，但他也没有支持它。他没有做出任何努力向立法者推销它，也没有让它成为法律，这几乎让该计划处于冰冷的边缘。
Well, what I don't like is not the plan, but borrowing itself. So I'm against that, but I think the lieutenant governor is as well.
好吧，我不喜欢的不是计划，而是借款本身。所以我反对，但我认为副州长也是如此。
When I interviewed Governor David Paterson, he was surprisingly sympathetic to the plan for somebody who had exiled it to limbo, even when it came to the borrowing. He said that he understood that Ravitch was just setting a ceiling if there had to be borrowing.
当我采访大卫·帕特森州长时，对于一个已经将它流放到边缘的人来说，他对该计划感到惊讶地同情，即使是在借款方面。他说，他理解拉维奇只是在如果必须借款的情况下设定了一个上限。
And what happened to the lieutenant governor in his first year is what happens to all of us in Albany. The ceiling became the floor, because on Planet Albany, there is no gravity, and light bends right around the Capitol. So rather than people understanding that this was a way to control borrowing, the legislature viewed it as a ticket for $2 billion.
而副州长第一年发生的事情也是我们在奥尔巴尼所有人身上都会发生的。天花板变成了地板，因为在“奥尔巴尼星球”上，没有重力，光线在议会大厦周围弯曲。因此，与其让人们明白这是一种控制借款的方法，立法机构反而将其视为20亿美元的入场券。
And so, at some point, the governor makes clear he's not embracing the plan. When do you find out about that? Does he talk to you about it privately? Do you see it?
所以，在某个时候，州长表明他不接受该计划。你什么时候发现的？他私下和你谈过吗？你看出来了吗？
Well, I take it emerged-- I don't remember precisely when-- He didn't criticize my plan. He just didn't support it.
嗯，我想它出现了——我不记得具体是什么时候了——他没有批评我的计划。他只是不支持它。
Were you surprised?
你感到惊讶吗？
Was I surprised? No, I actually felt that I didn't-- I wasn't able to convince him, and that maybe it was my failure.
我感到惊讶吗？不，我实际上觉得我没有——我没能说服他，也许这是我的失败。
Over the last few weeks, I've spent a lot of time trying to understand the politics of all this, why the legislators wouldn't embrace Ravitch's plan to show voters they were getting things under control. And I heard all kinds of explanations, on the record and off the record. Though some Republicans actually like the Ravitch plan and the fiscal order it imposes, it's just taken as a given that Republicans will vote as a group against any plan that comes from the Democrats. That's been the pattern lately, like in Washington.
在过去的几周里，我花了很多时间试图了解所有这些背后的政治，为什么立法者不愿意拥护拉维奇的计划来向选民展示他们正在控制事情。我听到了各种解释，在记录内和记录外。虽然一些共和党人实际上喜欢拉维奇计划及其带来的财政秩序，但共和党作为一个整体投票反对任何来自民主党人的计划，这被视为理所当然。这最近一直是这种模式，就像在华盛顿一样。
As for the Democrats, some support big parts of the plan of course. Others, I was told, don't want Generally Accepted Accounting Principles and transparency in budgeting. They like the current system where they can hide money and fudge things with last minute gimmicks. Some don't want the governor to get extra power to cut budgets without their approval, which he would get under the Ravitch plan if the legislature is unable to come up with their own cuts or revenue. I was told that some Democrats are so fed up with the governor-- he's a lame duck at this point-- they don't want to give him a victory on anything, including the Ravitch plan. And finally, Liz Kreuger, the Chair of the Select Committee on Budget and Tax Reform, told me the political reality is a lot of legislators simply don't feel the sense of emergency the lieutenant governor feels about the budget.
至于民主党人，当然有些人支持该计划的大部分内容。其他人，我被告知，不想要公认会计原则和预算透明度。他们喜欢当前的系统，在这里他们可以隐藏资金并通过最后一分钟的噱头来搞定事情。有些人不希望州长在没有他们批准的情况下获得削减预算的额外权力，如果立法机构无法自己提出削减或收入，根据拉维奇计划他将获得这种权力。我被告知，一些民主党人对州长感到非常厌烦——他在这一点上是一个跛脚鸭——他们不想在任何事情上给他胜利，包括拉维奇计划。最后，负责预算和税收改革特别委员会的主席利兹·克鲁格告诉我，政治现实是许多立法者根本没有感受到副州长对预算感到的那种紧迫感。
It's not clear that the sky is, in fact, falling. Some people realize it's an emergency, and some people think, "Well, everybody has always said there were problems, but we get by. Somehow we make it to the next year, and the next year, and the next year."
目前尚不清楚天空是否真的在塌陷。有些人意识到这是一种紧急情况，而有些人认为：“好吧，每个人都一直说有问题，但我们熬过来了。以某种方式我们熬到了明年，明年，明年。”
They haven't yet understood the consequences. They think that if somehow they can get through this year, they'll worry about next year, next year. And that is irresponsible given the fact that next year the deficit is going to be as great, if not greater.
他们还没有明白后果。他们认为如果他们能熬过今年，他们就会担心明年，明年。鉴于明年赤字将同样巨大，甚至更大，这是不负责任的。
And what do people say to that when you talk to them about that?
当你和他们谈论那个问题时，人们怎么说？
They thank me very much for my advice.
他们非常感谢我的建议。
So if they don't want the Ravitch plan, what are these legislators thinking should be done to get the state budget under control? Well, to understand a little about that I turned to State Senator Ruben Diaz. This week, Diaz nearly brought state government to a close by refusing to vote for the weekly emergency funding that's been keeping the state going for two months in the absence of a real budget. Diaz voted no because the governor had inserted into the emergency bill deep cuts in the overall state budget, cuts that Diaz opposes.
所以如果他们不想要拉维奇计划，这些立法者认为应该采取什么措施来控制州预算呢？嗯，为了了解一点，我转向了州参议员鲁本·迪亚兹（Ruben Diaz）。本周，迪亚兹几乎使州政府停摆，因为他拒绝投票支持在没有实际预算的情况下维持该州运作两个月的每周紧急资金。迪亚兹投了反对票，因为州长在紧急法案中加入了对整体州预算的大幅削减，迪亚兹反对这些削减。
Last week, we cut services to the poor and the needy, all the hospitals in New York City. Those are the hospitals that the people that send me here use. I cut them. What I'm doing, it doesn't feel right.
上周，我们削减了对穷人和有需要的人、纽约市所有医院的服务。那些是送我来这里的人使用的医院。我削减了它们。我所做的事情，感觉不对。
How do you think that the state should balance the budget?
你认为州政府应该如何平衡预算？
I am not a crazy person that only says, don't cut, don't cut. Because I understand that we, in the state of New York, have a fiscal crisis. And I know that money has to be found somewhere, or we have to cut. But I have presented two pieces of legislation--
我不是一个只会说“别削减，别削减”的疯子。因为我知道，在纽约州，我们面临财政危机。而且我知道必须从某处找到钱，或者我们必须削减。但我提出了两项立法——
One of these, he explained, would streamline the way that taxes are delivered to the state from credit card purchases. The other would let the state buy pharmaceuticals from Canada. Total savings, he says, $2 billion. He also wants to tax cigarettes sold on Indian reservations, something that's led to armed conflict and bloodshed when the states tried to impose it in the past. That would save another billion or two.
他解释说，其中一项将简化税收从信用卡购买中交付给州政府的方式。另一项将允许该州从加拿大购买药品。他说，总节省额为20亿美元。他还想对在印第安保留地出售的香烟征税，过去当各州试图征收这种税时，这曾导致武装冲突和流血。这将再节省一二十亿。
If you add my $3 billion or $4 billion, and you borrow 1 or 2 billion more, you don't need to cut anything. You have a balanced budget.
如果你加上我的30亿或40亿，再借1或2亿，你就不需要削减任何东西。你有一个平衡的预算。
Can I ask you-- the numbers that the budget office in the governor's office have presented, and that the lieutenant governor presented, show that this year, there would be a $9 billion deficit, next year, $13 billion, and increasing every year until it's $60 billion. Do you think those numbers are wrong?
我可以问你吗——州长办公室的预算办公室提供的，以及副州长提供的数字显示，今年会有90亿的赤字，明年会有130亿，而且每年都在增加，直到达到600亿。你认为这些数字是错的吗？
I don't know. I don't know. I don't know if they're real or not. I know that people use scare tactics most of the time, trying to inflict pain and fear. So I don't know how real it is.
我不知道。我不知道。我不知道它们是否真实。我知道人们大多数时候使用恐吓策略，试图造成痛苦和恐惧。所以我不知道它有多真实。
And when the lieutenant governor says that there's a structural problem in the budget, that every year there are more expenses than we're bringing in revenue, and that's increasing over the course of every year going forward, do you think he's right?
当副州长说预算存在结构性问题，即每年支出比收入多，而且这种情况在未来每年都在增加时，你认为他是对的吗？
Again, I am not in here to double guessing what people are saying. I'm here saying, we have other means, other ways, to balance the budget, not necessarily have to be on the back of the poor and the needy.
同样，我在这里不是为了猜测人们在说什么。我在这里是说，我们有其他手段，其他方式来平衡预算，不一定非得压在穷人和有需要的人身上。
Ravitch is an old school liberal. He not only idolized Franklin Roosevelt, he sits on the board of the Roosevelt Library, and owns an old WPA painting with scenes of The New Deal in action. His first political appointment was in 1966 by LBJ to a commission on urban problems. But he says we're in the worst economic contraction since Roosevelt's day. And we're not bouncing back any time soon.
拉维奇是一位老派的自由派。他不仅崇拜富兰克林·罗斯福，还是罗斯福图书馆的董事会成员，并拥有一幅描绘新政行动场景的WPA旧画。他的第一个政治任命是1966年由约翰逊总统任命的城市问题委员会成员。但他说我们处于罗斯福时代以来最严重的经济紧缩中。而且我们不会很快反弹。
We're in different waters, and the world is in different waters. Just look at the stories in the paper about Greece, and Ireland, and Spain, and Chile. We have all been spending more money than we are collecting in taxes.
我们处于不同的水域，世界处于不同的水域。看看报纸上关于希腊、爱尔兰、西班牙和智利的故事。我们所有人花钱都比我们收税收来的多。
And so Ravitch has been going around telling people in private conversations, in public speeches that he's been rethinking, and he thinks we all need to rethink, what government can do. Here he is at a group called The Association for a Better New York.
所以拉维奇一直在私下交谈、公开演讲中告诉人们他在重新思考，他认为我们都需要重新思考政府能做什么。这是他在一个名为“更好的纽约协会”（The Association for a Better New York）的组织里的讲话。
You know most people go into politics because they want to help people. And for years, that's what they've done. They've tried to help education, make healthcare available for more people. All of those are noble things, and what people in politics have done and have done very effectively. But there's a new economic paradigm out there, a very unpleasant one as we all know. And the political paradigm has not yet changed enough to accommodate the fundamental changes that have happened to our economy.
你知道大多数人进入政界是因为他们想帮助人们。多年来，这就是他们所做的。他们试图帮助教育，让更多人获得医疗保健。所有这些都是高尚的事情，也是政界人士已经完成并非常有效地完成的事情。但外面有一种新的经济范式，正如我们所知，一种非常令人不快的范式。而政治范式还没有发生足够的改变来适应我们经济中已经发生的根本性变化。
So Ravitch says that we need to have a conversation about what it is that we can afford. When I ask what this means, he throws out all kinds of ideas. One in four New Yorkers, he says, qualifies for Medicaid. Maybe those rules are too lenient. Maybe dozens of small school districts in the state should be consolidated to eliminate administration costs. And then there are taxes. Ravitch says we have to be careful, because higher taxes have driven people out of the state in the last decade. But he says there are some taxes that we should discuss.
所以拉维奇说我们需要就我们能负担得起什么进行对话。当我问这意味着什么时，他提出了各种想法。他说，四分之一的纽约人有资格获得医疗补助。也许这些规则太宽松了。也许该州几十个小校区应该合并以消除行政成本。还有税收。拉维奇说我们必须小心，因为更高的税收在过去十年中已经把人们赶出了该州。但他说我们应该讨论一些税收。
Not only is nobody engaging in that conversation, Ravitch says that our politics seem incapable of handling a fiscal crisis of the size that we are facing. Politicians today need to either cut services or raise taxes, which are the exact opposite of the things that they are used to doing to get elected.
不仅没有人参与那种对话，拉维奇说我们的政治似乎无法处理我们面临的这种规模的财政危机。今天的政客要么需要削减服务，要么需要增加税收，这与他们过去为了当选而做的事情截然相反。
The one politician that I talked to who seemed to understand at a cellular level the new paradigm that Ravitch talks about, as fate have it, is the man who decided not to carry Ravitch's fiscal plan to victory, Governor David Paterson.
我谈过的唯一一位似乎在细胞层面理解拉维奇所谈论的新范式的政客，命中注定，是决定不让拉维奇的财政计划获得胜利的人，大卫·帕特森州长。
I think something very alarming is happening, because the only group that ever seems to understand me when I'm talking to them-- and it doesn't matter whether they're Republicans or Democrats-- are other governors. No one wants to accept that our state is running out of money. And so the building can literally be burning, and they're still talking about programs that they want you to fund.
我认为发生了一些非常令人震惊的事情，因为当我与他们交谈时，唯一似乎能理解我的人——无论他们是共和党人还是民主党人——都是其他州长。没有人想接受我们的州正在用完钱的事实。所以大楼实际上可能正在着火，他们还在谈论他们希望你资助的项目。
Paterson says the worst has been when he's had to cut programs that he personally supported back when he was a legislator from Harlem.
帕特森说，最糟糕的时候是他不得不削减他以前担任哈莱姆区立法者时亲自支持的项目。
I was an advocate on issues such as domestic violence, and child sexual abuse, on hate crimes, and a lot of the social programs, and a supporter of some of the same individuals I've had to say no to. And I think because I'm saying no, and I'm a former supporter and friend, it's like a civil war. I've been insulted personally, and basically abused by some of those who have not liked the decisions that I've had to make. I think that my mind hasn't changed. I think my reality has changed, and I'm in the same circumstance that Lieutenant Governor Ravitch describes. We may have to step back and take a little different look at what government can accomplish right now. Because we've asked government to take on too many tasks that cost too much money. And here we are in a quagmire in many ways because of it.
我曾是家庭暴力、儿童性虐待、仇恨犯罪和许多社会项目等问题的倡导者，也是我不得不说“不”的某些相同个人的支持者。而且我认为因为我说了“不”，而且我是前支持者和朋友，这就像一场内战。我受到了个人侮辱，基本上受到了一些不喜欢我必须做出的决定的人的虐待。我认为我的想法没有改变。我认为我的现实已经改变，我正处于副州长拉维奇所描述的同样境遇中。我们可能不得不退后一步，对政府现在能完成的事情采取一点不同的看法。因为我们要求政府承担太多花费太多钱的任务。而由于这个原因，我们在许多方面陷入了泥潭。
Getting out of that quagmire, it's hard to stand on principles. Just last week, there was news out of Albany that to balance the budget, the governor and the legislative leaders, who'd spent the last few months adamantly opposed to any and all borrowing and had rejected Ravitch's plan mainly on that basis, figured out a way to patch another few billion into the budget by borrowing against state pension funds. Though officially, they don't call it borrowing. Ravitch was not surprised.
走出那个泥潭，很难坚持原则。就在上周，奥尔巴尼传出消息称，为了平衡预算，州长和立法领袖，也就是过去几个月坚决反对任何借款、并主要以此为基础拒绝了拉维奇计划的人，想出了一个通过抵押州养老基金来向预算中填补几十亿的方法。虽然官方上，他们不称之为借款。拉维奇并不感到惊讶。
Coming up, as promised, crusaders trying to do the right thing for their country during a budget crisis, and this time, actually succeeding. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，正如承诺的那样，十字军在财政危机期间试图为他们的国家做正确的事，这一次，确实成功了。那将在芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际公司的节目继续后的一分钟内。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our show, the social contract, and what happens to it during dire economic times. We've arrived at Act Two of our show. Act Two, If You Were Stranded on a Desert Island and Could Only Bring One Economic Plan.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天在我们的节目中，社会契约，以及它在可怕的经济时期会发生什么。我们已经到达了节目的第二幕。第二幕，如果你被困在一个荒岛上，只能带一个经济计划。
In this act, we turn to another country where people reached a crisis point and had to reevaluate how to run the country. The country is Barbados. Alex Blumberg tells what happened.
在这一幕中，我们转向另一个国家，那里的人们达到了危机点，不得不重新评估如何治理国家。这个国家是巴巴多斯。亚历克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）讲述了发生的事情。
When you hear the story of Barbados in the 1990s, you'll think yourself, "I have never heard of people getting together and doing what this entire nation decided to do. It's remarkable." And it's even more remarkable when you compare Barbados to one of its neighbors, Jamaica.
当你听到90年代巴巴多斯的故事时，你会想：“我从来没有听说过人们聚在一起做这个整个国家决定做的事情。这太了不起了。”当你将巴巴多斯与它的邻国之一牙买加进行比较时，这就更了不起了。
The two countries should be very similar. Both were colonized by the British. Both gained independence in the mid-1960s, and then became parliamentary-style democracies. And both started from essentially the same place economically. One wasn't much richer than the other. But to give you a sense of life in Jamaica today, let's go to the side of a road next a little strip mall as a couple of women selling fruit out of cardboard boxes. And they say life here is so bad that the police-- the metroman they call them-- steal from them regularly.
这两个国家应该非常相似。都曾被英国殖民。都在1960年代中期获得独立，然后成为了议会制的民主国家。而且它们在经济上基本上都是从同一个地方开始的。一个并没有比另一个富裕多少。但为了让你了解今天牙买加的生活，让我们去路边的一个小购物中心，那里有两个妇女在纸板箱里卖水果。她们说这里的生活太糟糕了，警察——他们称之为“地铁人”（metroman）——经常偷她们的东西。
The metroman come here, [UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
地铁人来到这里，[模糊短语]
They take away our stuff and lock we up.
他们拿走我们的东西并把我们锁起来。
Wait. The police come and take away your stuff?
等等。警察来了，拿走了你们的东西？
Yes. We have to beg [UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
是的。我们不得不乞求[模糊短语]
We don't get it back. Them carry out their children's homes and take it for themselves.
我们拿不回来。他们把他们孩子的东西拿走并占为己有。
Some days I will cry, hungry, you know.
有些日子我会哭，饿着肚子，你知道的。
Compare that to this.
把它与这个进行比较。
Now, we're in a mall in Barbados, which looks basically like a mall in the United States. Tell me about life in Barbados. How is it?
现在，我们在巴巴多斯的一个购物中心，它看起来基本上就像美国的一个购物中心。告诉我关于巴巴多斯的生活。怎么样？
For me, it's great absolutely. Absolutely fantastic.
对我来说，绝对很棒。绝对精彩。
And why do you say that?
你为什么这么说？
Well, over the years, we have had excellent governance in terms of the people who run the country. We've had--
嗯，多年来，我们在治理国家的人方面拥有出色的管理。我们拥有——
I'm just laughing because you never, ever hear anybody say that. I'm just trying to imagine going out in the United States.
我只是在笑，因为你从来没有听到任何人这样说。我只是试图想象去美国。
This is a fact in Barbados. You just have to compare us to the rest of the world.
这是巴巴多斯的一个事实。你只需要把我们与世界其他地方进行比较。
Some quick statistics for comparison. Five decades after independence, median income in Barbados-- twice what it is in Jamaica. Literacy rates in Barbados are over 95%. In Jamaica, it's estimated that 1/5 of the population is functionally illiterate. And Jamaica has one of the highest murder rates in the world, while Barbados is near the bottom.
为了进行比较，一些快速的统计数据。独立五十年后，巴巴多斯的中位数收入——是牙买加的两倍。巴巴多斯的识字率超过95%。在牙买加，据估计五分之一的人口是功能性文盲。牙买加拥有世界上最高的谋杀率之一，而巴巴多斯接近底端。
So what did Barbados do so right? Well, to answer that question, come with me now to the 1990s.
那么巴巴多斯做对了什么？好吧，为了回答这个问题，现在随我来到90年代。
[MUSIC - "EVERYBODY DANCE NOW" BY C&C MUSIC FACTORY] This is C&C Music Factory's monster hit from 1991. It actually has nothing to do with Barbados, but 1991 is when our story begins. And as the '90s were getting under way, Barbados was doing OK. But then, oil prices went up. The world went into recession. Tourism is a huge industry on Barbados and foreigners weren't taking as many beach vacations, which created a big, big problem for Barbados.
[音乐 - C&C Music Factory的《EVERYBODY DANCE NOW》] 这是C&C Music Factory 1991年的大热单曲。它实际上与巴巴多斯无关，但1991年是我们的故事开始的时候。随着90年代的到来，巴巴多斯表现尚可。但随后，油价上涨了。世界陷入了衰退。旅游业是巴巴多斯的一个大产业，外国人并没有像以前那样去海滩度假，这给巴巴多斯造成了一个非常非常大的问题。
When you're a small country, you rely on the rest of the world to make almost everything you need, toothpaste, or wheat, or C&C Music Factory CDs. And if you want to buy things from say, the US, some importer somewhere in your country has to have actual US dollars to pay for those things. So where do they get these dollars?
当你是一个小国时，你依靠世界其他地方来制造几乎你需要的一切，牙膏，或小麦，或C&C Music Factory的CD。如果你想从例如美国买东西，你国家的某个进口商必须拥有实际的美元来支付这些东西。那么他们从哪里得到这些美元呢？
Well, this is an over simplification, but basically, Americans come to Barbados and spend them on hotels and coconut drinks, or importers from America buy Barbados rum and pay in dollars. And then, Barbados can turn around and spend those dollars on stuff from America. It's iron clad. No foreign dollars, no goods from abroad.
嗯，这是一个过于简单的说法，但基本上，美国人来到巴巴多斯，把钱花在酒店和椰子饮料上，或者来自美国的进口商购买巴巴多斯朗姆酒并用美元支付。然后，巴巴多斯可以反过来用这些美元购买来自美国的东西。它是铁板钉钉的。没有外国货币，就没有来自国外的商品。
This is a problem a lot of countries get into. You may have heard the term foreign exchange crisis. That's what this is. And in 1991, Barbados was facing one. The first people who knew this were employees of The Barbados Central Bank where the supply of American dollars and all those other foreign currencies had been steadily dwindling. DeLisle Worrell is the Governor of The Barbados Central Bank.
这是一个许多国家都会陷入的问题。你可能听说过“外汇危机”这个词。这就是它。1991年，巴巴多斯正面临一场危机。第一个知道这一点的人是巴巴多斯中央银行的员工，那里美元和所有那些其他外币的供应一直在稳步减少。德利尔·沃雷尔（DeLisle Worrell）是巴巴多斯中央银行行长。
In about mid-1991, we had no foreign exchange reserves.
大约在1991年中期，我们没有外汇储备。
You literally had no reserves at all?
你们真的根本没有储备？
Yeah, maybe about $10 million or something like that.
是的，也许只有大约1000万美元左右。
$10 million to a central banker, even one on a tiny Caribbean island, that is nothing. And so, the Barbadian government did what almost every government in this situation does, it went to the IMF, The International Monetary Fund, and asked for a foreign currency loan. The idea being, we'll borrow a couple hundred million dollars US now, and then, when Americans start coming back to our beaches, we'll pay you back in dollars. The IMF did what it always does. It said, "Sure. We'll give you the money, but there are strings attached so you don't get into this situation again. You need to rearrange your economy so you don't need as many foreign dollars, which means basically, you want your citizens to spend less money on stuff from abroad."
对一位中央银行家来说，即使是在加勒比海的一个小岛上，1000万美元也根本算不上什么。因此，巴巴多斯政府做了几乎每个政府在这种情况下都会做的事情，它去了国际货币基金组织（IMF），并要求一笔外币贷款。想法是，我们现在借几亿美元，然后，当美国人开始回到我们的海滩时，我们将用美元偿还你们。国际货币基金组织做了它总是做的事情。它说：“当然。我们会给你们钱，但有附加条件，这样你们就不会再次陷入这种境地。你们需要重组你们的经济，这样你们就不需要那么多外国货币，这意味着基本上，你们希望你们的公民在国外商品上少花钱。”
But since almost everything in Barbados comes from abroad, that basically amounts to the entire nation of Barbados needs to spend less. And the way you keep people from spending is sort of dreadful. You need them to get poorer.
但由于巴巴多斯几乎所有东西都来自国外，这基本上等于整个巴巴多斯国家需要减少支出。而你让人们停止支出的方式是相当可怕的。你需要让他们变得更穷。
So here's how you do that. You can devalue your currency. So if it costs five Barbados dollars to import a C&C Music Factory CD, now it would cost 10; ditto for bread, toothpaste-- Prices for everything go up. Or, you can cut government services, which-- think about it-- means all kinds of people have less money in their pockets. Neither, of course, is very popular.
所以这就是你这样做的方法。你可以让你的货币贬值。所以如果进口一张C&C Music Factory的CD需要5个巴巴多斯元，现在它需要10个；面包、牙膏也是一样——所有东西的价格都上涨了。或者，你可以削减政府服务，这——想想看——意味着各种各样的人口袋里的钱都变少了。当然，这两种方法都不太受欢迎。
I am Leroy Trotman. I am the general secretary of the Barbados Workers' Union.
我是勒罗伊·特罗特曼（Leroy Trotman）。我是巴巴多斯工会联盟的总秘书长。
Leroy Trotman is often called, Sir Roy. Knighthood seemed pretty common in Barbados. I ran into a couple of knights while I was there. And Sir Roy was one of several people called to an emergency meeting by the prime minister in mid-1991 to discuss the crisis and what the IMF wanted Barbados to do.
勒罗伊·特罗特曼经常被称为罗伊爵士。在巴巴多斯，爵位似乎很常见。我在那里时遇到过几位爵士。罗伊爵士是1991年中期被总理召集进行紧急会议讨论危机以及国际货币基金组织希望巴巴多斯做什么的几个人之一。
Now Sir Roy, and most people in Barbados at the time, had no love for the IMF. They'd seen what had happened to other countries in the Caribbean when the IMF got involved, higher unemployment, massive currency devaluations, sometimes riots and violence. It seemed everywhere the IMF went, trouble followed. Fairly or not, they blamed the IMF and the terms it imposed on countries it lent money to.
罗伊爵士和当时巴巴多斯的大多数人一样，对国际货币基金组织没有任何好感。他们已经看到了国际货币基金组织介入时加勒比地区其他国家发生的事情：更高的失业率、大规模的货币贬值、有时还有骚乱和暴力。似乎国际货币基金组织走到哪里，麻烦就跟到哪里。无论是否公平，他们指责国际货币基金组织及其强加给它贷款国家的条件。
We took a position that we would see ourselves as a country which was being invaded by the IMF. And our approach thereafter was that we had to resist this invasion. And that's what we actually called it.
我们采取的立场是，我们将自己视为一个正在被国际货币基金组织入侵的国家。此后我们的方法是我们必须抵制这种入侵。这就是我们实际称呼它的方式。
An invasion?
入侵？
Yeah, the trade union called it that.
是的，工会这样称呼它。
But the unions knew that they'd need help resisting the IMF. And so, they hatched what seems like a fairly strange plan for a trade union. They decided to band together, not just with other unions, but with management as well, the business councils, and chambers of commerce on Barbados, to join together to confront the IMF and set the terms of the loan. Tony Walcott is the executive director of the Barbados Employers' Confederation, a business group. And at first, he says, the employers were dubious.
但工会知道，他们需要帮助来抵制国际货币基金组织。于是，他们策划了一个对工会来说看起来相当奇怪的计划。他们决定联合起来，不仅与其他工会，而且与管理层一起，即巴巴多斯的商业委员会和商会，联合起来面对国际货币基金组织并设定贷款条件。托尼·沃尔科特（Tony Walcott）是巴巴多斯雇主联合会的执行主任，这是一个商业团体。起初，他说，雇主们持怀疑态度。
I think employers, traditionally, didn't see themselves as being part of the problem, if you want to put it that way. But it was so serious that something had to be done. And this is when all parties came together and said, "Look, devaluation is not an option. Massive wage cuts or retrenchments in public service was not an option."
我认为雇主们传统上并没有将自己视为问题的一部分，如果你想这样说的话。但这太严重了，必须做些什么。这就是各方聚在一起并说：“看，贬值不是一个选择。大规模的工资削减或公共服务裁员不是一个选择。”
And so, Sir Roy Trotman, representing workers, found himself side by side with Tony Walcott's group, representing managers and business owners, in front of the IMF to press the case that some of the IMF solutions would do more damage than good.
因此，代表工人的罗伊·特罗特曼爵士发现自己与代表经理和企业主的托尼·沃尔科特的团体并肩作战，在国际货币基金组织面前施加压力，要求其某些方案弊大于利。
We told the IMF, for example, that we would not agree to a larger size of classrooms. They wanted to double the size of classrooms. They wanted to have people going to a hospital have to pay for services. And our position was that we were going to be under an IMF program for awhile, but we were going to come out from it. And that when we came back out, our people had to be healthy, and they had to be educated, and ready to take on the job of building the country again. And the IMF was persuaded by us. I think the government was also persuaded. The employers were side by side with us in these arguments.
例如，我们告诉国际货币基金组织，我们不同意扩大班级规模。他们想把班级规模扩大一倍。他们想让去医院的人支付服务费用。我们的立场是，我们将接受国际货币基金组织的一段时间的计划，但我们将从中走出来。当我们回来时，我们的人民必须健康，他们必须受过教育，并准备好承担重建国家的工作。国际货币基金组织被我们说服了。我想政府也被说服了。雇主们在这些争论中与我们站在一起。
These arguments stretched on for months, the employers and employees on one side, the IMF on the other, the government sort of stuck in between. The main sticking point-- wage cuts. Remember, lower wages would mean people would buy less from abroad, which would mean they'd need fewer US dollars. So the government was proposing a big wage cut, which the unions and employers, together, opposed. They staged a general strike, and held a massive two-day demonstration, the largest in Barbados history. It's estimated that 10% of the island's population took to the streets. Here's Sir Roy Trotman addressing the crowd at that march.
这些争论持续了几个月，一边是雇主和雇员，另一边是国际货币基金组织，政府夹在中间。主要的症结——工资削减。记住，较低的工资意味着人们会从国外购买较少的东西，这意味着他们将需要较少的美元。所以政府提议大幅削减工资，这遭到了工会和雇主的共同反对。他们发动了一次大罢工，并举行了大规模的两天示威，这是巴巴多斯历史上规模最大的一次。据估计，该岛10%的人口走上了街头。这是罗伊·特罗特曼爵士在游行中向人群发表讲话。
Let me tell you, ladies and gentlemen, [CHEERING] the people marched against the walls of Jericho. And because the people had the will to march, the walls of Jericho fell.
让我告诉你们，女士们先生们，[欢呼] 人们在耶利哥的城墙前游行。因为人们有游行的意志，耶利哥的城墙倒塌了。
But in the end, the speeches, the general strike, the 30,000 marchers in the street, could not contradict the basic reality that the country of Barbados would run out of money unless it figured out a way to get its people to spend less. And so the government, under pressure from the IMF, insisted on an 8% pay cut for all public sector workers across the board. And it's at this point that things depart from the usual script where each side digs in for a brutal war of attrition.
但最终，演讲、大罢工、街头3万名游行者，都无法反驳巴巴多斯国家将用完资金的基本现实，除非它找到办法让人民减少支出。因此，在国际货币基金组织的压力下，政府坚持对所有公共部门员工实行8%的全面工资削减。就在这一点上，事情脱离了通常的剧本，每一方都在进行残酷的消耗战。
Sir Roy and the leaders of the other unions knew that fighting on-- more strikes, more demonstrations, which might get out of hand and lead to violence-- all of that could kill an already fragile tourist industry. So they went back to their members, and in meeting hall after meeting hall, all over Barbados, explained to the union rank and file, "We're sorry, but this is the deal."
罗伊爵士和其他工会领袖知道，继续战斗——更多的罢工、更多的示威，可能会失控并导致暴力——所有这些都可能扼杀已经脆弱的旅游业。所以他们回到会员那里，在巴巴多斯各地的会议厅里，向工会普通成员解释：“我们很抱歉，但这就是交易。”
Do you remember a specific meeting in a hall where you felt like, "Man, what am I going to tell these people?"
你记得在某个大厅里你觉得“天哪，我要跟这些人说什么？”的具体会议吗？
Every time I stood up. [LAUGHTER] It was difficult. I mean sometimes it didn't become easy to go into groups, because people told you about your heritage. Some of them had wishes for your future that you didn't exactly agree with. But the job had to be done, and if you are leader, you have to lead.
每次我站起来时。[笑声] 这很困难。我的意思是，有时去小组并不容易，因为人们谈论你的遗产。他们中的一些人对你的未来有你并不完全同意的愿望。但工作必须完成，如果你是领导者，你就必须领导。
Yes, we effectively agreed to an 8% pay cut.
是的，我们实际上同意了8%的工资削减。
Here's Dennis de Peiza, head of another union organization.
这是丹尼斯·德·佩扎（Dennis de Peiza），另一个工会组织的负责人。
We had to choose between the lesser of two evils, either taking a pay cut, or having many Barbadians on the street without a job. To put it in a very simplistic way, all we said, "Save Barbados." Two words, and we had the interest of the country paramount.
我们不得不在两个坏选择中选择一个，要么减薪，要么让许多巴巴多斯人在街上失业。用非常简单的方式来说，我们所说的只是：“拯救巴巴多斯。”两个词，我们将国家利益放在首位。
The Barbados workforce in the trade union movement took a very patriotic stance.
巴巴多斯的劳动和工会运动采取了非常爱国的立场。
Again, labor leader Sir Roy Trotman.
再次说明，劳工领袖罗伊·特罗特曼爵士。
And even now, I still feel a sense of pride that the workers in Barbados rallied behind us, not 100%, but to the great level that they did. And the employers were with us step by step in all of this.
即使现在，我仍然感到一种自豪感，即巴巴多斯的工人们在我们身后团结起来，虽然没有100%，但达到了很高的水平。而雇主们在这一切中一步步地与我们站在一起。
That last part is important. The self-sacrifice was contagious. If the unions could go against their very reason for existence and lend their grudging support to wage cuts, then the business community could go against the thing it held most dear, profits. Here's Tony Walcott who represents the businesses.
最后一部分很重要。自我牺牲是会传染的。如果工会能够违背他们存在的最根本原因，并给予减薪以勉强支持，那么商界也可以违背它最珍视的东西——利润。这是代表企业的托尼·沃尔科特。
The mercantile community did was say, "Look, we will accept a lower margin, or a lessening margin, just to be able to hold prices." You kept the retail price fixed at a number. So it eroded your margin a bit.
商界所做的是说：“看，我们将接受较低的利润率，或利润率的降低，只是为了能够保持价格。”你把零售价固定在一个数字上。所以它侵蚀了一点你的利润。
So here you are. The price of oil is going up. So that means that the price of all sorts of other things are going up, because everything is tied to oil And instead of raising it-- that level-- they just took it. Instead of taking 50--
所以在这里，油价正在上涨。这意味着所有其他东西的价格都在上涨，因为一切都与石油挂钩。而不是提高它——那个水平——他们只是接受了它。而不是接受50——
It ate into their margins.
它蚕食了他们的利润率。
So instead of getting 50%, they were going to get 40%, 30%, something like that?
所以他们得到的不是50%，而是40%，30%左右？
Yes, that's correct. That's correct. Well, as Sir Roy said, nobody wanted the devaluation, and the mantra was, "Save Barbados." And people were just prepared to tighten their belts a bit and ride out the rough patch that we were going through.
是的，那是正确的。那是正确的。好吧，正如罗伊爵士所说，没人想要贬值，口号是“拯救巴巴多斯”。人们只是准备勒紧裤腰带，度过我们正在经历的困难时期。
Workers and employers came up with other ideas as well. For example, remember the world was in recession at this time. So layoffs were already up in Barbados. These wage cuts were going to make that even worse. So the unions and employers came up with an idea to try to reduce the impact of these layoffs, or as they were termed, retrenchments. Again, here's Tony Walcott with the business community.
工人和雇主也想出了其他想法。例如，记住那时世界正处于衰退中。所以巴巴多斯的裁员已经增加了。这些工资削减会使情况变得更糟。所以工会和雇主想出了一个想法，试图减少这些裁员（或称为缩减规模）的影响。再次，这是代表商界的托尼·沃尔科特。
We started to develop tools like insisting that if there were going to be retrenchments in a household, both bread winners would not be retrenched. At least one had to be retained to ensure that there was money coming in.
我们开始开发工具，例如坚持如果家庭中要进行裁员，两个养家糊口的人不会同时被裁。至少必须保留一个，以确保有钱进来。
Everyone chipped in. Even pension funds sold off their foreign assets, American stocks and bonds, as a way of bringing American dollars back into the system. In the end, this collective sacrifice worked. The recession ended. People came back to spend their vacations in Barbados, and the Barbadian economy continued to grow. Within five years, Barbados had paid back its loan to the IMF, and real wages were higher than they were before the 8% pay cut.
每个人都出了力。甚至养老基金也抛售了他们的外国资产，即美国的股票和债券，作为将美元带回系统的一种方式。最终，这种集体牺牲奏效了。衰退结束了。人们回到巴巴多斯度假，巴巴多斯经济继续增长。五年内，巴巴多斯偿还了给国际货币基金组织的贷款，实际工资比8%的工资削减前更高。
And Barbados society seemed permanently altered. These meetings between employers, employees, and government were so effective that they became formalized into what's called the Social Partnership. I was actually in Barbados during one such meeting, the yearly gathering of all three groups, which is called the Week of Excellence. Tony Walcott, who represented the employers, and Sir Roy and Dennis de Peiza, who represented labor, were all there together in the same room when I was talking to them.
而且巴巴多斯社会似乎发生了永久性的改变。这些雇主、雇员和政府之间的会议非常有效，以至于它们被形式化为所谓的“社会伙伴关系”（Social Partnership）。我在巴巴多斯时，正值这三个团体进行年度聚会，被称为“卓越周”（Week of Excellence）。当我和他们交谈时，代表雇主的托尼·沃尔科特，以及代表劳工的罗伊爵士和丹尼斯·德·佩扎，都坐在同一个房间里。
And what they do during these meetings is essentially try and see things from each other's point of view. For example, hotel management is always like, "Be extra nice to the guests or they'll take their vacations in Antigua." And labor is like, "Uh, I'm on my lunch break." The Social Partnership tries to get labor and management to recognize their common interests in keeping tourists coming to Barbados; for example, this new pilot program they've started to improve productivity in the hotel industry. Basically, that means to get the staff to provide better service to the guests, but also to reduce waste, be more profitable for the hotel. Again, here's Tony Walcott.
他们在这些会议期间所做的基本上是尝试从对方的角度看待事物。例如，酒店管理总是说：“对客人格外友善，否则他们会去安提瓜岛度假。”而劳工说：“嗯，我正在午休。”社会伙伴关系试图让劳工和管理层认识到他们在吸引游客来巴巴多斯方面的共同利益；例如，他们开始提高酒店业生产力的这个新试点项目。基本上，这意味着让员工为客人提供更好的服务，但也减少浪费，对酒店更有利可图。再次说明，这是托尼·沃尔科特。
If they recognize that their reward is going to be based on efficient use of, let's say cleaning supplies. hence, any gains you're able to make is being paid as a productivity bonus.
如果他们认识到他们的奖励将基于高效使用（比方说）清洁用品。因此，你能取得的任何收益都将作为生产力奖金支付。
So basically, what you're doing is you're establishing what exists on Wall Street, whereas if people have a good year, they get a bonus. You're putting it on the level of the gas station attendant, and the chamber maid, and people in the hotel service, and the bartender.
所以基本上，你正在做的是建立墙上存在的东西，即如果人们有一年好光景，他们就会得到奖金。你把它放在了加油站服务员、女佣、酒店服务人员和调酒师的水平上。
That's correct. It's being based on output.
那是正确的。它是基于产出的。
Now we're staying at the Hilton. If I talk to the person who's cleaning my room at the Hilton, will they be familiar with this?
现在我们住在希尔顿酒店。如果我与希尔顿清理我房间的人交谈，他们会熟悉这个吗？
Yes, because Hilton is in the pilot scheme.
是的，因为希尔顿在试点方案中。
Yeah, Hilton, we do a lot of training.
是的，希尔顿，我们做了很多培训。
This is O'Neal, a Hilton bartender I met. He said that as part of this pilot scheme, employees at the Hilton go through lots of trainings where they're encouraged to think like their managers do, i.e. from the point of view of the customer.
这是我遇到的希尔顿调酒师奥尼尔（O'Neal）。他说作为试点方案的一部分，希尔顿的员工会经历大量的培训，他们被鼓励像管理层那样思考，即从客户的角度出发。
Like if you're an employee, you put yourself in a guest situation. Well, you can be guests. And you try to do like a role play on it-- you know what I'm meaning-- to get feedback on. You know what I mean? That's how they do it.
如果你是员工，你会把自己放在客人的位置上。好吧，你可以成为客人。你会尝试进行角色扮演——你知道我的意思——以获得反馈。你知道我的意思吗？他们就是这样做的。
And he was also saying there are productivity bonuses. Do you know about that?
而且他还说有生产力奖金。你知道那个吗？
Yeah.
是的。
And how does that work?
那是怎么运作的？
Extra effort, and if you do something that goes beyond your job commitment, they give bonuses.
额外的努力，如果你做了一些超出你工作承诺的事情，他们会给奖金。
Have you gotten a bonus?
你拿到过奖金吗？
Yeah. I'm always going beyond. It's part of the job. I always do.
是的。我总是做得更多。这是工作的一部分。我总是这样做。
And employers try to see things from labors' point of view, especially when they're in negotiations, and labor might not believe the claims management is making. Again, here's Tony Walcott, of the business community.
雇主们也会尝试从劳工的角度看问题，特别是在他们谈判时，劳工可能不相信管理层提出的主张。再次说明，这是商界的托尼·沃尔科特。
Several of the companies have opened up their financials to the union. These are private companies. Their financials are not generally published, yet officers in these companies are prepared to sit with the union and to share financial information with the union. The union has been satisfied, based on the presentations we've made, that the companies do not have the ability to pay. But the key driver was we have to sustain existing employment levels. And if it means that we don't take a pay increase to be able to allow our brother to stay employed, that has been the driving force for both the employer and the workers' representative side.
几家公司已经向工会公开了他们的财务报表。这些是私营公司。他们的财务报表通常不发布，但这些公司的官员准备与工会坐下来，并与工会分享财务信息。工会根据我们所做的陈述感到满意，即这些公司没有支付能力。但关键的驱动力是我们必须维持现有的就业水平。如果这意味着我们不涨工资以使我们的兄弟能够保持就业，那一直是雇主和工人代表方的驱动力。
For Tony Walcott, it all comes down to one simple thing, which, when he said it, I could not believe what I was hearing.
对于托尼·沃尔科特来说，这一切归结为一个简单的事情，当我听到他说这句话时，我无法相信我听到了什么。
Trust. And to me, that is a key factor in the whole cohesion of the Social Partnership that we've got here.
信任。对我来说，这是我们在这里建立的社会伙伴关系的整个凝聚力的关键因素。
The reason I'm laughing is just because you represent the employers on Barbados. And again, I'm just putting this in the American context. It's just sort of like-- I mean it's just hard to imagine an American leader of a business association talking about how much they trust the labor unions. It just doesn't seem possible, right?
我之所以笑是因为你代表巴巴多斯的雇主。再说一次，我只是把这放在美国的环境中。这有点像——我的意思是很难想象美国商业协会的领导人谈论他们有多信任工会。这似乎是不可能的，对吧？
No, but it's about trust.
不，但这关乎信任。
In trying to figure out how much the rest of the world can learn from Barbados, people I spoke to are divided. Some point out that what Barbados did would only work in a tiny society. It's only 300,000 people after all. So it's harder to vilify the other side in negotiations. But others say that anyone facing this type of budget crisis, which today, includes Greeks, Spaniards, Hungarians, New Yorkers, to name just a few-- Anyone can do what Barbados did. Bring all sides together, talk, listen, and try to see things from each other's point of view. It's essential, they say, because if you don't, the long-term consequences can be devastating. The long-term consequences look like Jamaica.
在试图弄清楚世界其他地方能从巴巴多斯学到多少时，我交谈过的人们分歧很大。有些人指出，巴巴多斯所做的事情只在一个微小的社会中才有效。毕竟只有30万人。所以谈判中很难妖魔化对方。但其他人说，任何面临这种预算危机的人，今天包括希腊人、西班牙人、匈牙利人、纽约人，仅举几例——任何人都可以做巴巴多斯所做的事情。把各方聚在一起，交谈，倾听，并尝试从对方的角度看待事物。他们说这是必不可少的，因为如果你不这样做，长期后果可能是毁灭性的。长期后果看起来像牙买加。
Jamaica in the mid-1970s faced the identical crisis Barbados faced in the '90s, a foreign exchange crisis. The Jamaican Central Bank had run almost completely out of foreign dollars. The country had no money to buy the things it needed from abroad, and like Barbados, it was forced to turn to the IMF for a loan.
牙买加在1970年代中期面临着巴巴多斯在90年代面临的相同危机，即外汇危机。牙买加中央银行几乎完全用完了外国美元。国家没有钱购买它需要从国外获得的东西，而且像巴巴多斯一样，它被迫向国际货币基金组织求贷。
Jamaica's leader at the time was a bright and charismatic man named Michael Manly, popular with the rich and the working class. But unlike the leaders in Barbados, he didn't bring the country together to share the burden of becoming temporarily poorer. He didn't build trust between workers and business owners. The thing that almost all middle class Jamaicans alive at the time remember-- in 1975, he made a famous speech saying that if Jamaicans didn't like what he was doing, there were five flights a day leaving for Miami. Thousands of middle class Jamaicans took his advice and left, including the guy I first heard this whole story of Jamaica and Barbados from, an economist named Peter Henry.
牙买加当时的领导人是一个名叫迈克尔·曼利（Michael Manly）的聪明而富有魅力的人，深受富人和工人阶级的欢迎。但与巴巴多斯的领导人不同，他没有把国家凝聚在一起共同承担变得暂时贫穷的负担。他没有在工人和企业主之间建立信任。当时活着的几乎所有中产阶级牙买加人都记得一件事——1975年，他发表了一次著名的演讲，说如果牙买加人不喜欢他正在做的事情，每天有五趟航班飞往迈阿密。成千上万的中产阶级牙买加人听从了他的建议并离开了，包括我第一次从一个叫彼得·亨利（Peter Henry）的经济学家那里听到整个牙买加和巴巴多斯故事的人。
He was nine when he moved to America with his parents. He's now the dean of the business school at New York University where he takes a professional interest in what happened to his old country. The exodus of foreign capital and middle class Jamaicans, that Peter was a part of, crippled the Jamaican economy. It actually shrunk an average of 2% per year for 15 years in the '70s and '80s, a statistic that makes economists gasp. And successive Jamaican governments faced with the declining tax revenues continued to borrow, so that today, almost 50% of the money the Jamaican government collects goes towards paying interest on debts from the past. Here's Peter Henry.
他和父母搬到美国时才九岁。他现在是纽约大学商学院的院长，他对他老国家发生的事情有职业兴趣。彼得参与的那次外资和中产阶级牙买加人的大逃亡，使牙买加经济陷入瘫痪。它实际上在70年代和80年代的15年里平均每年缩水2%，这是一个让经济学家倒吸一口凉气的统计数据。而面对税收收入下降的历届牙买加政府继续借款，以至于今天，牙买加政府筹集的资金中几乎有50%用于支付过去的债务利息。这是彼得·亨利。
You tend to think about economic disasters as happening in autocratic countries where people are trying to fleece the populace. That isn't necessarily the case. This is a smart man, a man with a big heart, who meant to do well. And this is why I think it's all the more powerful, the lesson. Even in places where governments are trying to do the right thing, and trying to actually empower their citizens, if they follow bad policies, there will be substantial, long-run consequences.
你倾向于认为经济灾难发生在人们试图欺骗民众的专制国家。这不一定是真的。这是一个聪明的人，一个心地善良、一心想做好事的人。这就是为什么我认为这个教训更加有力。即使在政府试图做正确的事情，并试图真正赋予公民权力的国家，如果他们遵循错误的政策，也会产生实质性的长期后果。
Of course, in a crisis like the one Barbados and Jamaica faced that many governments around the world are facing right now, at the time it's implemented, bad policy can feel like good policy. People keep their jobs and their salaries. And good policy can feel bad. There are protests, and marches in the street, and calls for the government to resign. The true consequences to Barbados and Jamaica were only revealed over time as they marched steadily down their divergent paths. Barbados isn't a miracle, but after decades plodding slowly along, it now looks like one.
当然，在巴巴多斯和牙买加所面临的、世界各地许多政府目前正面临的那种危机中，在实施时，糟糕的政策可以感觉像是好政策。人们保住了工作和工资。而好的政策感觉很糟糕。街头有抗议、游行，要求政府辞职。巴巴多斯和牙买加的真实后果只是随着时间的推移才显现出来，因为他们坚定地走在各自不同的道路上。巴巴多斯不是一个奇迹，但在几十年的缓慢前进之后，它现在看起来像一个。
Alex Blumberg is part of Planet Money that we co-produce with NPR News. Their blog and twice weekly podcasts, where they explain the world's economy entertainingly and in normal language anybody can understand, is at www.npr.org/money. [MUSIC - "ISLAND IN THE SUN" BY THE MERRYMEN]
亚历克斯·布隆伯格是与NPR新闻共同制作的“金钱星球”（Planet Money）的一部分。他们的博客和每周两次的播客，在那里他们以任何人都能理解的正常语言娱乐性地解释世界经济，网址是www.npr.org/money。[音乐 - The Merrymen的《ISLAND IN THE SUN》]
Well, our program was produced today by Jane Feltes and me, with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Sarah Koenig, Lisa Pollak, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producers is Julie Snyder. Seth Lind is our production manager. Emily Condon is our office manager.
嗯，我们的节目今天由简·费尔特斯（Jane Feltes）和我制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格、本·卡尔霍恩（Ben Calhoun）、莎拉·柯尼格（Sarah Koenig）、莉萨·波拉克（Lisa Pollak）、布莱恩·里德（Brian Reed）、罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien）、阿丽莎·希普（Alissa Shipp）和南希·厄普戴克（Nancy Updike）参与。我们的高级制片人是朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）。塞斯·林德（Seth Lind）是我们的制作经理。艾米莉·康顿（Emily Condon）是我们的办公室经理。
[ACKNOWLDEGEMENTS] Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight of our program by our boss Mister Tony Malatia who has decided to move his experimental, quantum physics research that he's so involved in from Fermi Lab in Chicago to Albany, New York, which seems like a much more interesting place for it.
[鸣谢] 我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播国际公司分发。WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督由我们的老板托尼·马拉蒂亚（Tony Malatia）先生负责，他决定将他参与其中的实验性量子物理学研究从芝加哥的费米实验室搬到纽约奥尔巴尼，这看起来是一个更有趣的地方。
Because on Planet Albany, there is no gravity, and light bends right around the capital.
因为在“奥尔巴尼星球”上，没有重力，光线在议会大厦周围弯曲。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week, hopefully over this cold, with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周回来，希望感冒好了，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。